est-ce que vous voilà autour de la table
vous êtes jaloux ou jalouse mathieu de
leur bus non sont qu'au contraire le
fait qu'on puisse sentir que l'autre
peut nous échapper c'est ça qui est
excitant away ah oui c'est ce que vous
sentez avec moi depuis longtemps des
domaines où ces salles et réciproquement
ces belles conséquent jamais choquer
j'en avais fait qu'on tourne autour le
pote on est autour de moi pendant
longtemps
on avait fait des kilomètres autour de
la terre je pense que c'est faux je
pense que si un jour je disais c'est
fini m'intéresse futur mariana hop vous
seriez e mail i-mode dit et bien dit
rémois pour voir ça comme ça dans la
france entière pour la france entière
est ok cyril
c'est fini
c'est fini entre nous terminez n'est pas
crédible j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé un plus
jeune ah oui abu tunisien qui a dix ans
de moins oui qui fait mieux qu'elle a un
amant et remuez bien la cup
c'est ça non mais alors à accéler
marielle me donnes tu étais pas crédible
à l'arrêt c'est parce que tu crois moi
ball aus bat
lola lola ce que vous êtes jalouses avec
jean-marie parce qu'il est quoi la
sortie c'est vrai que j'en voyais là il
aida de succès c'est que ces spectacles
c'est vrai que quand j'étais plus jeune
j'étais vraiment très jalouse et
maintenant j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
maintenant on aurait pu m'amener jeu
mais j'ai vraiment appris à faire un
travail sur moi parce que je faisais des
crises mais c'est horrible ah ouais
vraiment j'ai été voilà match quand même
scorpion ascendant scorpion je suis très
possessive je connais je suis acheté un
bordel franchement chez un baroudeur
mais du coup en fait ça fait quand même
tellement d'années et tout et je sais
qu'ils voient là je sais qu'on est unis
par des oeufs qui bouge pas une oreille
franchement je me pose pas la question
je lui demande juste de passer pas j'ai
pas dit que la plupart voilà ouais ça
fait pas prier quoi ouaip avait pas pris
non mais j'ai pas envie d'avoir mon
image qui soit salie je veux pas le
savoir parce que ça me ferait de la
peine est d'accord il bouge pas une
horreur vous savez bien c'est un manque
de confiance en soi pourquoi c'est à
dire que si vous vous êtes jaloux c'est
parce qu'en fait on pour vous là vous
jouez le tigre mais au fond de vous il
ya un jour son pagne
il ya
[Rires]
presque jalouse mais naim non je suis
enfin je suis attentive attenti
attentive mais pas jalouse je fais pas
de crise chez pas de choses comme ça
mais évidemment je fais je regarde ce
qui se passe autour de mon amoureux mais
en revanche c'est pas une possession
soit rien
l'espace rien c'est pas la campagne
dororo plein en pleine campagne que
quelqu'un d'aller le chercher une
croyance les jeunes les week-ends c'est
ça non mais sérieux tu crois vraiment tu
vas leur trouver que le palefrenier la
non mais voilà après après on les uns et
les autres seront pas à l'abri d'un coup
de coeur ne pas me perdre en local
j'aimerais bien sûr de la carrière de
benjamin castaldi
la jalousie détruit le couple de toute
façon
on a parlé sur deux soit vous n'êtes pas
des banalités vous êtes non mais non
mais ça c'est fini avait fait tout ça
cela va fermer
début les derniers chiffres ça m'a fermé
c'est maintenant qu'il faut parler tout
ça c'est fini tout ça c'est radio là
c'est fini allez au dinar est de dire
que l'humanité médecins une banalité oui
je suis jaloux rousselot bâtard
les chiffres de la fevs non mais sans
déconner je les ai l'écart de leur
genèse et les chiffres gfk
- qu'animaux tv met
à niveau tous les meilleurs sont les
lézards de moins de 20 ans en tout cas
son intérêt mais ça n'intéresse pas les
gens oui alors oui je suis jaloux
je les emmerde
ça fait chier
[Applaudissements]
c'est que l'homme chez toi agen on a
envie que tu me salis
sarrio regarde pas la belle teinte
autres au soleil et normalement
on boit quatre ans de chanter du rail là
où je t'aime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je lui dire mais j'avais pas lu devant
vous avez pu la mener jusqu ici
je sais que vous devez monter princesse
à 20h
à la con vas lire et la cavalière et
lors de l'envoi merci
on dirait vraiment un champion
d'équitation michel petits jeux
olympiques j'ai pas de stars marqué chez
sur la tête de ma mère tu t'intéresses à
tous les sports on tue ton balech total
pendant les cela dit et en juillet
frères tek tomates en deux minutes il
tire un orque
foot
est une des chances de médailles a nommé
ça y est et là je vois des gars comme
ans était en train de boire des chevaux
qu'il faudra
avant tout une heure en prime time tout
les copains sont sortis sont raspoutine
et son tuba confrères et toi tu es comme
asséché watts en train de regarder aller
on a baby show
et
voit des erreurs que toi tu vois et le
présentateur le cheval car c'est mon
petit erreur un
annabelle à fait ok
tu vois et après après fou
et tous les chevaux font pareil et toi
tu as l'impression que c'est tout à fait
pareil mais le gars qui vous garde te
dis non à la belle a été moins bien que
les autres elle va rater la médaille
deux à cinq ans mais sans décoller et là
je sais pas d'où êtes madame el bicho
non mais je vous jure c'est très chiante
à jouer des jeux vous sautez alors qu'on
peut en faire autant allez allez merci
voilà c'est ça c'est une personne qui
fait partie de l'équipe on ne sait pas
encore pourquoi elle est là mais elle
est là c'est isabelle c'est important
c'est la caution de l'émission le quota
non merci franchement les deux là non je
vais vous dire la vérité je gagne un
nouveau chroniqueur qui va venir posez
vous les bonnes questions
non vraiment vous êtes sur un siège je
ne dirais pas éjectable déjà il est
remplacé ça vous êtes sur la selle du
vélo là quand même vous êtes jaloux vous
encore
comme aulas vous en foutez non mais là
pour moi quelqu'un qui n'est pas jaloux
c'est quelqu'un de suspect le suspect
g2g de théorie c'est soit c'est
quelqu'un qui a des choses à se
reprocher d'accord qui n'est pas jaloux
à ce qui se fait discret bien sûr que ce
soit quelqu'un qui sont fous complet de
la personne donc moi je suis jalouse pas
mal modéré mais quand même et vraiment
jalouse au delà de l'irrespect au delà
de livres respect
on dirait une chanson de johnny si on
est donnée j'adore ça veut dire qu'au
moment où la personne ne te manque de
respect l'a tué jalouse pour la personne
mais aussi pour tout monter je vous
garantis bon moi je vous dire je ne
parle pas des tours à cooking in what
was foot tu arrives la table et là elle
te vois en train de galoches une meuf
place et du respect là c'est de les
radier la dalle de voix commence avec un
autre que meiway
qu'avez-vous quick a même entendu je l'
ai entendu ce qu'ils apprennent à nice
voilà donc ça voilà ça ça marche ça ça
dégage voilà c'est ça on est d'accord au
delà de l'irrespect mais oui pourquoi
pas au-delà de dire spa le bagarreur de
l'équipe
enfin on en a fait de la boxe au collège
j'ai eu un petit peu boxer celui-ci n'a
pas sa part le sait pas où est sa part
elle lui c'est vraiment le gars tu sais
quand tu as une embrouille et un gars
fait toujours cammas et
ses longues anormalement dans la bagarre
[Rires]
la longue
bagarre il ya une bagarre comme à tsahal
choqués et hagards
et l'assimilent c'est celui-là qui prend
la scène musicale ayala chemin qui part
en
elle la connaît c'est ce gars là alors
j'y vais tous vous êtes alors
je ne sais pas du coup en ce moment je
surveille particulièrement ouais tout ce
qui est rendez-vous extérieur ah oui ça
rendez vous lors des rendez-vous
extérieur quand c'est sur plusieurs
jours sur plusieurs semaines il faut
s'entraider
on va tous dit je vais acheter n'eut pas
quel regard une semaine après
la wii ja oui il faut se poser des
questions oui alors j'y vais
j'accompagne maintenant ah ouais non
mais accompagne que ce soit un rendez
vous médical et vous
qu'attendez-vous familia mais jacques on
paie l'année c'est à dire ça maintenant
elle va rejeter deux baguettes de
baguette
et comment
et
j je vous avez rendez vous avec le
dermato
la métaphore au collège c'est aussi la
confiance en l'autre et l'amour oui
confiance en l'autre mais tout est mené
jury ostéopathe rendez vous
professionnel le café le reste on ne
sait jamais ouais donc je préfère y
aller voir ce qui se passe voilà ça
devait être un chien vous est ce qu'un
nombre élevé est ce que vous êtes jaloux
alors il ya 10 15 ans j'étais jalouse
par amour propre un paradis c'est
toujours mecs entier regarde quelqu'un
de plus jeune de plus beau voilà
maintenant je m'en fous complètement
départ de toute façon il manie qu'ils
mais plus maintenant qu'à 40 ans j'ai
un respect
il est tranquille lui pour là encore
c'est que
la donne de l'espoir oui alors c'est
beau mais on peut dire tout et n'importe
quoi
non mais le reste la phase au rire ça
donne de l'espoir savard est encore
vivante quand même
regardez
j'ai été vacciné abeilles l'autre voilà
encore appeler un taxi côté
[Rires]
2,4 c'est super je me bats
je ne croyais pas en un homme qui dit à
sa femme je t'aime en plus encore
aujourd'hui que j'étais payé tous les
plans de rien et moi pour moi il ya 90%
de huit ou dix ans oui je fais partie
des 10%
dieu soit loué mais bon moi il ya 90 %
le mytho web dont je vous dis et j'ouvre
l'oeil à chaque moment sur les mythos
voilà on a
testé mensonges et ouais bah oui bah
alors le match où les tests autour du
cas oui lady chatterley l'écuyère nos
marges et et quand j'écris quand j'étais
jeune
non non j'étais pas jalouse quand
j'étais jeune parce que j'étais plus
sûre de moi d'accord sans témoin très
politique maintenant c'est en fait je
sentais que j'étais où je j'imaginais
qui étaient introuvables un très bon et
maintenant en vieillissant alors là du
coup j'ai trouvé le grand amour et là
effectivement même si c'est un peu le
ver dans le fruit la jalousie rend
complètement par les vers dans le fruit
cieux c'est insupportable j'avoue que je
peux quand même être un petit peu
vigilante voilà c'est dit gilles ans
c'est la vigilance et la vigilance
attentive attentive est ce que vous
regardez dans le téléphone de votre mec
là bien sûr lola gens mariés ce que tu
regardes dans son bebop
welsh la chanson minitel garde sur son
talent ou pas ouais je regarde son vrai
nom ouais ouais après on est pas mis un
corps voilà je suis moi jalouse qu'avant
mais je partais très loin donc faut
savoir que je le suis encore pas mal
jalouse donc de temps en temps je fais
genre passe moi ton tel est en fait j'ai
une curiosité je n'y arrive pas alors à
ne pas regarder des messages vais
révéler un truc franchement j'ai encore
rien fait beaucoup beaucoup de mal mais
je veux rêver les gens à il y a sur les
téléphones dans certaines personnes bien
entendu dont je ne fais pas pas
n'est ce pas guillaume
il y a un truc vous allez sur la
calculatrice ouais
exactement soit calculatrice vous faites
un code sur la calculatrice et ça met
une autre interface et vous avez des
trucs à des conversations chekade et au
feu des balles comme à
exactement c'est le fun parallèle mais
de voter c'est une application oui sa
part de calculatrices méjean tôt il a sa
rue ou pas moi j'en serviront pour le
travail
sérieux jeux jeux de ferrari oui oui ça
l'est pour le travail voici mois alors
moi je ne mange pas de ce pain-là
pardonnez-moi mais comment mais vous
connaissez un journaliste
l'info la fois l'info l'info l'info
match là on n'avait rien à cacher donc
côté je n'ai rien à cacher rien à cacher
vous pouvez prendre
un
[Rires]
téléphone tout ce qui a pu lui comme un
escabeau enfants accès à votre téléphone
et d'accepter le favori ils ont accès
quand je suis pas loin
chargez votre code je jouerai toujours
le faire à la pub ah oui vrai on colle
ouais nom ne vous dit pas mais sans
personne à mon coach devrait s'élever à
8 8 on n'en parle pas ben c'est pas ça
du tout en douceur
qui fait toujours le bal de byron suite
huit familles de suite non c'est ma tête
derrière spa but de suite c'est vrai je
te lis est à mes rôles et la pauvre est
celui qui est vrai mais j'adore quand
j'ai tous les combien votre code tous
les jours mon code tous les jours les
fans aussi non
mais on va redonner moi pourquoi nous
changer de code tout le temps si vous
n'avez rien à cacher mais oui c'est
bizarre est-ce que ça me soit en temps
je sens un truc qui me dit non parce que
ça me rassure dans le fait que j'ai
toujours une bonne mémoire et je peux
retrouver mon code
non non non c'est tout le monde à quel
moment vous avez arrêté deux mois pour
des couëts
vous êtes l'osha nona vous êtes l'on
touche à boulets rouges sur rfm
vous est ce que vous êtes jaloux jaloux
maladif ah c'est vrai ouais bah c'est
des souvenirs douloureux mais quand
j'étais à google chine
[Applaudissements]
je contactais la personne et je mettais
des coups de pression ah oui j'ai déjà
fouillé un téléphone en vrai ça joyce a
déjà causé une rupture
s'était pavané téléphone c'est les
portes de l'enfer à windsor horrible
horrible est en fait je trouve toujours
un truc comme fusible a évidemment c'est
que même si tu es avec quelqu'un qui est
soi-disant blanc bleu et à toi c'est
trop ça et si pour ça comptera pas là
dedans même que dans quelques mois de
plus aux bleus mais deux blancs plus que
je dis ou sait jamais tu vois même
apathie madiun qui m'envoie un coeur ça
peut faire je ne veux pas je veux pas et
à l'envers c'est ce que vous regardez le
téléphone jamais d'avis jamais de la vie
chacun sont le téléphone c'est comme un
slip
arriver si on regarde le nom on est
toujours déçu
[Applaudissements]